okay so sue liam is a very expensive
lanthanide it's very expensive because
it's very hard to separate it from its
neighbors the lanthanides from left to
right and to go this contraction where
they get smaller and smaller and over on
the right-hand side at this point
they're all of a very similar size now
we can separate them now but it is quite
difficult to do and therefore quite
expensive so thulium is not used very
often however a thulium as well as being
able to attain the +3 oxidation state is
also one of those ones which can obtain
the +2 oxidation state which means that
chemists are now beginning to find uses
for it which they hadn't expected before
so you may see the use of thulium
increase in years to come because it's
very hard at isolate because it's a very
similar size to its neighbours it took a
guy called Charles James in 1911 a
famous 15,000 times of recrystallization
to isolate Thuli when a pure albeit as a
chloride but appearing on the less
compound for the first time